more and more of our personal
information is easily available online
with all of the modern technology that's
out there and the various websites that
are out there it really does become a
lot more tricky to be able to safeguard
you know your personal information as
far as home addresses and things like
that the leaked supreme court draft has
recently led to protesters taken to the
streets outside the private homes of
supreme court justices
what can you as a homeowner do to keep
your information private not readily
available to anyone online metro
lieutenant alan larson one of the most
common places that a lot of criminals
look or even just people who might be
upset with somebody else if they want to
find a personal address is the county
assessor's
office you can cover a real estate
purchase and keep your home address
cloaked we do recommend you know people
putting their their houses into some
type of a living trust your trust will
own the home and since you can call the
trust anything you want it makes it
harder for you and your address to be
located generally it's smart if you
don't want people knowing that it still
belongs to you to use a different name
other than your common last name most
multiple listing services require homes
to be pulled off online websites within
a day of closing follow up make sure
this happens type in your name and
google home address removing the listing
will clear your home's information from
online systems whether a private citizen
or a public figure it's an uphill battle
to keep your information including your
home address off the internet